hello everybody and welcome to the first
video my TV basics with Python tutorials
series in this video we're gonna be
talking about is actually just acquiring
TV what TV is and all of that and really
just testing the installation so let's
go ahead and get started first of all
what is TV so this is the key view
website kiva.org and whenever you go
there you'll just be sent to this
hashtag home so keavy is just a
cross-platform software development kit
so you can think of it it's just a GUI
some way to make gooeys with python kind
of like tkinter only the kicker with TV
is that it's cross-platform and of
course being cross-platform to like
linux mac OS and windows isn't too
phenomenal obviously you can do that
with tkinter but where this shines is it
is cross-platform even into mobile with
iOS and Android and with that it also
can interact with special features of
your phone so for example on your phone
you have for one a touch screen but also
there's various hand gestures that you
can do with the phone like the basic
ones would be you know like this is
supposedly a soon and then you can do
like this and that zooms out stuff like
that you're able to do and you
alternatively you can also you know do
spins all kinds of stuff and that's
really specific to the operating system
that you're on
so what keavy does is it kind of allows
for that and also you can connect to say
like the android api and you can access
the you know the phone's camera let's
say or the gyro or or whatever
so with that keeping zack obviously
quite powerfully there's a lot of cool
stuff that you can do and it's
relatively simplistic to get started and
you you can basically use this and then
you can use something like billdozer for
example for android you can convert it
to an Android application put it in
Google Play and you're all set you're
gonna get rich so not really but anyway
so that's at let's go ahead and get
started so what do we need so for keavy
to work you need pygame first then key v
key be kinda uses pi games so to get PI
first you're going
I get PI game then keavy so obviously if
you're on say Linux you would use
something like sudo apt-get install
Python PI game if you have pip already
installed you can just say pip install
PI game and if you're on Windows you can
do this as well if you have a 32-bit
operating system anyways so I'll hit it
I'm using a 32-bit Python I hit it
alright since I have a 64-bit version of
Python it gets a little angry with me so
I have to use a different different
thing and I'll show that as well but
anyways for most people either sudo
apt-get or pip install will work also I
have a pic installed tutorial videos so
if you have any confusion with how to
use pip install check that out so
finally I will just show the final place
you can get it if you are already
familiar with pip is you can come to
this website here and he's got all of
the Python packages it used to be just
simple binary dot exe s but he's moved
to wheels curses but anyways you can
come here and you can just type in PI
game and actually here's TV as well I
just happen to be the first thing that
was found but you can get the key view
wheel so for example I'm on 3.4 so this
is C Python 3.4 and then this is for a
64-bit windows so I would download this
one and wait for it and then I would go
click on PI game and I would download
this one for PI game same thing so now
you've got those two wheels and again
this is for if you're like a 64-bit
version of Windows or for whatever
reason you couldn't get the other stuff
to work for you but anyways once those
are downloaded you'll go to your
downloads page and we'll only actually
I'm going to close out of this because
I'm going to use something different now
but anyways you can come here just go to
your computer and on downloads you can
just hold shift right click and we're
going to open the command window there
that opens up a command went into that
directory so then for me I could do
something like this pip install and I
already forgot what they're calling them
so so it's it starts with PI games so
pip install PI game and I'll hit tab and
that's the full wheel so now I could hit
enter and this will install based on
that wheel file although I still got it
an error here okay I know what it's
doing it's referencing my
I have two versions of Python here 2.7
and 3 so to reference three very
specifically seen colon slash Python 34
slash I think it'll be script slash pip
install and let's try that one more time
and in fact let me uh I could go here we
go edit default we'll go to properties
and hopefully we can make this text a
little bigger
there we go fonts so y'all can read it
okay so anyways that should be it I
can't member if it's a capital S or not
I'm pretty sure it is hit enter and see
what happens
yeah there we go so that installs PI
game for me anyways since I'm on a
64-bit obviously if you're on 32-bit you
can use this process as well you would
just download the different let's say
you run Python 3 for 32-bit this would
be your download instead so now well now
though we've got Python we can all see
the same thing with TV soap it actually
let's just do an up arrow and we'll just
delete this original one and then we'll
say TV there's the key V wheel hit enter
wait for it downloads on pax and abba
tall ready have TV so it says everything
was satisfied but anyway so that's the
installation process for TV it's going
to vary slightly depending on your
operating system although basically
every new version of either 2 7 or 3/4
is going to come with pips so pip is
probably the easiest method and then
again if you have a 64-bit or some other
operating system that at least for
Windows you can use this this website
here I'll put a link to this website in
the description if I forget someone
remind me and I will put it there I like
to forget so anyways once you have that
you're ready to go ahead and get started
so I'm going to just minimize this all
for now I don't think I'll need it again
but first let's go ahead and just import
TV and make my font here bigger as well
I forgot to do that sorry
fly import TV and just make sure it you
can run this so just save and run that
and uh make sure you don't get any
errors this is just some info you'll see
that keavy spits out a lot of stuff so
anyway so that's that so import KB as
long as that works you installed things
correctly or at least up to this point
now if you if you're following along
right on this video you'll find that you
are right when this videos released
you're probably using TV one point 8.0 I
think and so what you can do is be if
you're using something that is a newer
version of TV that maybe isn't available
to older versions you can and you might
see that people suggest that you always
do something like this so TV require and
you can require a version number so one
point eight point zero I think is the
one that we're using I already forgot
but let's just keep you require one
point eight point zero and see if we
have any issues now yes so V one point
eight one zero everything's fun and if
you if someone is using an older version
of TV and they try this it just won't
work so and it'll you know give them an
error like oh you don't have that so
let's let's try one point nine point
zero not quite sure little pop-up here
but yeah right so it just gives you an
errand says too old anyway this isn't
totally necessary you can have a key B
script without it but most people will
just add the latest version but again if
they have an old if the person has an
older version it doesn't necessarily
mean it won't run so I'm going to
comment it out for now but you might
want to add that in a production version
if you're using features that require a
certain version living along um so now
we're going to go ahead and do is create
our first app class and so this is
basically um going to be the crux of
your TV application so instead of import
TV we're actually going to do from TV
import app and actually it's capital a
mobile this is a glass
so from kV import app you can have the
key be require if you want but I'm not
going to leave it there just because
it's not really necessary for the stuff
we're using now the next thing that
we're going to do is we're going to go
ahead and go from TV UI x dot label we
want to import
Abell so what is this now key D is
actually extensively um documented both
in the key v code itself and on the key
V website but let's say you're curious
about the key V code so we're staying
from K V dot u IX dot label and we're
importing this label and what label is
is it's just straight-up like a label
you can think of a label much like the
labels into kinder if you're familiar
but a label can also be a button and a
button is an element of a label so
anyway let's let's look at at that real
quick so I'm gonna open up computer C
Python 34 Lib it'll be insight packages
and then we're looking for key V so here
is key V we open up K V and we can see
we are from K V dot u IX so we'll go
into the UI X directory dot label so now
we're looking for label script here it
is we're going to right click edit with
idle and this is our actual label dot pi
so we can come down here and we can see
that all this is just commented stuff
but here's our class label and then we
can basically see this is the
initialization so this is always run and
then these are all of like the elements
of labels but you can see that you've
got you know you can update the texture
you this is the create label more update
they're on touch down so you can see
there's already code created for if you
were to press then there's you know
basically just a whole bunch of stuff
anyway if you want to read through all
the stuff that is possible with a label
you can and obviously you can see it's
extremely well documented actually in
the code itself I mean everything has
far more documentation and there's like
more documentation here than code so
anyway that should be pretty useful but
as you can see I mean this is all for
just label right so there's a lot of
stuff you can do with keavy but you can
also go to the keavy website and they
have quite a bit of documentation for
various things on their website so you
can go docks and within docs I'm pretty
yeah there's like a search here so you
can search things in the documentation
that you're looking for us if you're
looking for a button or if you're
looking for canvas drawing or whatever
you can search it but we'll talk a
little bit more on that in a little bit
so now what we want to do is just build
a quick simple application just to show
you guys the backend so it's a lot keavy
is a lot like Pi game where there's the
back end is really written for you you
don't need to write code although with
Pi game you have to write code for a
button but you know the right code for
like where is the mouse on the screen
that's already done for you you don't
have to write code to do like the
multi-touch app you know apps and stuff
like that you have to do any of that
your job is just to focus on the logic
so it's actually it's really useful in
that regard so anyways let's go ahead
and do we'll create or create our class
and we're going to call this simple TV
and that's our simple Keeney class and
then in here for the inheritance we're
going to inherit from the app class so
let's key B and then we open up the app
class here and this is your app class
not too much here but that's what we're
inheriting from so basically we're
inheriting all of this and here is your
actual app class so this entire thing
here this is all the code that we've
just inherited so again you don't just
understand like that's what you're
that's what I mean by they've done a lot
of the work for you because this is all
the work you would you normally probably
need to write yourself but someone has
already done it for you so anyways we're
inheriting from app now moving right
along also if you're not too familiar
with object-oriented programming my
channel
typically we build everything with
functions but when it comes to gooeys
object-oriented programming is
definitely the way to go so we use that
here I do have an object-oriented crash
course with using tkinter as an example
so if you're a little confused you can
check that out I will put links to that
as well anyways class simple Katey
inheriting from app now we're going to
just do is define our build and we just
passed the traditional self there again
if you don't understand that check out
the chroniclers define build and then
we're just going to have it return a
capital L label and then we're going to
say the text
of that label again if you want to know
more about the parameters possible with
label
look at that Q dot UX that label and
then the label class within and we're
just going to say the typical hello
world exclamation mark because this
computer is really excited to say hello
now that's that so we have our app and
that's pretty much all we have to do at
this point so now we're just going to
say is if name equals main just that
typical line you don't really need this
this is just so if you were to import
this script it would only run if you
were actually running the script so this
one this code wouldn't run if you we
were importing it but anyway simple
Cavey and then dot run and that will
actually run our script so we can go
ahead and save and run that now I'll
actually already know it as sample Cavey
simple TV and then what was the actual
error that was thrown cannot import name
app from TV in oh I know what I've done
right
so from Cavey dot app right so what
we're just like label right we were this
is the the actual script name so from TV
dot up here we open that up that's from
Q dot a p-- and then we're trying to
import the app class wherever it is
that's like I said so much documentation
anyway reporting app which by the way
inherits from event dispatcher so as you
can imagine there's a lot of code that
is rewritten or already written for you
anyway simply keep the app run that
should be all set now we for root and
here we have our hello world application
boom okay so 15 minutes basic TV
application but what's neat is this
application already could run just about
all the major operating systems Android
iOS Windows Linux and Mac OS I think I
was what I forgot anyway pretty cool
obviously your work this isn't really
interactive in any way although we can
resize this application alright
which is pretty neat and you can see it
all just basically by default kind of
fixes whatever it needs to fix so again
that's pretty cool and we basically did
all that in very few lines of code here
so anyway what we're gonna be talking
about it's kind of expanding on this
expanding more of your options for the
GUI there's actually a lot of more to
cover as far as the basics are concerned
so that's what we're we talking about
next is kind of expanding on this so
anyway stay tuned for that if you guys
have any questions or comments please
feel free to leave them below otherwise
as always thanks for watching things for
all the sports subscriptions until next
time